bonjour à tous Dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition de
jean-jousel le climatologue a été
auditionné par les sénateurs sur le 5e
rapport du JEC le Groupe
intergouvernemental d'experts sur le
climat qui a rendu un rapport assez
alarmant sur le réchauffement climatique
on en parle avec le sénateur écologiste
de Loire Atlantique ronand Dantec
bonjour bonjour vous êtes également donc
porte-parole mondial des villes dans la
négociation climatique vous avez assisté
à la conférence de Varsovie sur le sujet
conférence qui a abouti à un accord in
extrémiste un petit peu difficile
comment êtes-vous sorti de cette
conférence avez-vous été déçu par cet
accord difficile à obtenir non pas
vraiment parce que Varsovie est une
conférence intermédiaire il faut bien
comprendre qu'on est dans un cycle de
négociation qui se terminera à Paris en
2015 donc on savait qu'à Varsovie un
certain nombre de pays seraiit dans la
posture durcirit la négociation pour
être en position de force avant euh
Paris dans dans 2 ans malgré tout ça
reste une négociation très difficile on
voit bien que le fait puisque c'était un
des sujets de Varsovie le fait que les
pays développés n'ai pas tenu leurs
engagements autour des des fameux 100
milliards de dollars qui était
l'engagement du du fond vert de de
Copenhague durci euh ne crée pas de
confiance entre les né ateur que du coup
la Chine est redevenu un petit peu le
porte-parole des pays du Sud et la Chine
du coup a aussi un peu remis sur la
table l'engagement pris àurbane donc
c'est compliqué la Chine et l'Inde donc
les pays émergents ont été très
difficiles dans cette négociation
vis-à-vis des pays développés dont il
ils estiment que ce n'est pas forcément
à eux de faire le plus d'effort en
matière d'émission de CO2 oui mais c'est
aussi en partie une posture puisque les
Chinois savent très bien que s'il n'y a
pas d'engagement de leur part il ne peut
pas y avoir voir d'accord climatique
donc c'est pour ça qu'à Durban pour la
première fois pour la première fois ils
avaient bougé en acceptant d'aller eux
aussi sur des sur des engagements mais
je je l'ai dit c'est une négociation
intermédiaire c'est de la posture
l'important c'est Paris Laurent Fabius
est venu officiellement accueillir la
candidature officielle de la France pour
la conférence de Paris jusqu'à présent
c'était officieux il a parlé d'agenda
positif ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi s'appuyer sur les
dynamiques des acteurs de ceux qui font
au quotidien et dans ce cadre-là
l'action des villes des territoires est
absolument il y avait dans le programme
de Varsovie un moment très officiel avec
Bank Kyon sur la place des villes et des
régions donc il faut trouver pour Paris
une un mode de négociation qui n'est pas
celui de Copenhague c'est-à-dire moi je
je parle un peu du d'une matrice il faut
croiser les engagements des états
verticaux et les dynamiques des secteurs
horizontaux à l'échelle mondiale c'est
cette dynamique globale qui peut
permettre un accord à à Paris Varsovie
ne pouvait qu'être difficile maintenant
malgré tout il faut mobilisé et je crois
que le rapport du GC dit à quel point il
y a urgence on ne peut pas se permettre
d'échecs à Paris en 2015 justement vous
avez assister donc à cette audition de
jean-jousel donc climatologue membre du
JEC du Groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts sur le climat comment qu'en
pensez-vous de cette urgence voilà
climatique est-ce que pour vous c'est
vraiment une situation
alarmante oui mais on le on le sait
maintenant depuis plusieurs rapports du
GC on sait que l'humanité joue son
avenir sur sa réponse collective au défi
du du changement climatique le problème
qu'on a c'est que beaucoup de sénateurs
vont pendant ces auditions dire oh là là
c'est très grave il faut agir et dans la
réalité de leurs amendements à chaque
fois qu'on a des lois qui touchent la
question climatique ils vont dire pas de
contrainte pour les entreprises il y a
d'autres urgences pas pas de réforme
fiscale pas d'écotaxe et que ce cette
contradiction là elle est elle est
centrale aujourd'hui à l'échelle
française et à l'échelle mondiale
c'estàdire il faut un moment qu'on fasse
passer le long terme l'avenir de nos
enfants de nos petits-enfants avant des
sujets immédiats ou en tout cas trouver
des équilibres et je crois par exemple
que la loi sur la transition énergétique
qui ira à la fois sur la réduction de la
part du nucléaire sur la réduction des
émissions de gaz effet de serre mais qui
ira aussi sur l'efficacité énergétique
donc la réduction des factures pour
chaque habitant de notre pays sera un
moment déterminant moi je crois que le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui à l'échelle
française comme mondiale c'est cette
incapacité à intégrer le long terme en
période de crise dans nos choix
politiques justement est-ce que vous
estimez que le gouvernement actuel prend
suffisamment en compte la question
environnementale alors très clairement
le fait que François Hollande décide
d'accueillir la conférence à Paris est
quand même un choix courageux puisqu'il
joue en terme diplomatique sont
quinquena sur la conférence de de Paris
donc la France à partir de là ne peut
pas être en contradiction avec l'accueil
de de de la conférence donc la loi sur
la transition énergétique devra
obligatoirement être une loi ambitieuse
moi j'attends notamment de la France
qu'elle défendre à l'échelle européenne
un objectif de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre d'au moins 50 %
en 2030 il faut qu'on soit vraiment à
l'offensive aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
dire que ce gouvernement est délaissé la
question énergétique Hollande ho ont
toujours appppelé l'objectif de 50 % de
nucléaire et l'objectif du Facteur 4 sur
le sur le CO2 en 2050 maintenant on est
à l'heure de vérité la manière dont la
loi arrivera au Parlement dans le 2e
semestre 2014 dira si c'est des mots des
discours ou si c'était une volonté
partagée et je crois que dans dans
l'accord socle entre écologiste et
socialistes on sait très bien que c'est
là aussi l'heure de vérité oui mais pour
l'instant effectivement beaucoup de
paroles mais peu d'actes on il y a
encore pas mal de sujets de conflit
entre les écologistes et le gouvernement
sur qu'on parle de Notre-Dame des Landes
du nucléaire de fonheim enfin tous ces
sujets qui posent quand même vraiment
problème pour l'instant alors il y a un
certain nombre de désaccords connus
Notre Dame nland en fait partie je
remarque quand même que depuis que nous
avons signé cette cet accord il n'y a
plus d'intervention et plus de travaux à
Notre Dame des Landes donc c'est un
sujet jeelai aujourd'hui je je pense
surtout que les décisions restent
fondamentalement devant nous qu'on a
perdu du temps qu'on ne peut pas se
permettre d'en perdre plus mais si je
prends l'exemple de
l'écotax le le rapport que je viens de
de faire comme rapporteur de la loi de
finance sur sur les routes je propose
des solutions pour sortir du blocage et
je vois que Jean-Marc Erraud lui aussi
dit il faut pas attendre un an il faut
essayer d'aller le plus vite possible
parce que derrière c'est un milliard
perdu pour le budget de l'État ça veut
dire que ce que ne paieront pas les
transporteurs routiers c'est les impôts
qui les paieront donc on voit que sur ce
point-là nous sommes en accord avec avec
le gouvernement et que nous avons les
mêmes objectifs donc je crois qu' il
faut effectivement avoir une vision non
caricatural de de cet accord entre
écologistes et socialistes il y a eu des
avancées sociétales par exemple le
mariage pour tous pour prendre un un un
exemple il y a des points de désaccord
au niveau fiscal on aurait pas fait
comme cela sur le cice très probablement
mais il y a surtout beaucoup d'échéances
qui sont devant nous et des échéances où
il ne s'agit pas juste d'être à examiner
de manière un peu nombriliste le rapport
entre les socialistes et les écologistes
c'est est-ce que la société française
aujourd'hui veut s'engager avec nous
dans la transition écologique c'est ça
la question centrale et à ce niveau-là
je crois qu'on a besoin de travailler
ensemble peut-être effectivement de
renforcer notre coproduction et nos
échanges merci beaucoup ronand DC
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tout de
suite donc retour à la salle pour cette
audition de Jean jousel sur le 5e
rapport du
JEC je sais bien sûr que que dans dans
cette commission vous
êtes pour beaucoup d'entre vous sinon
pour tous très très au fait de des
problèmes de liés au changement
climatique je vois le sénateur denu nous
discutions tout à l'heure depuis le
temps que
nous disons essayons de de mettre cel
sur l'agenda réalement
politique donc je vous remercie d'être
là et je vais essayer de laisser pas mal
de temps à des questions alors quand
même on avait préparé pour ceux c'est
peut-être utile parce que je je vais
vous dire de tourner la page de temps en
temps c'est peut-être utile que vous
ayez ce document si sans ça c'est pas
très grave non plus vous inquiétez pas
mais il doit toujours avoir sur la table
je pense voilà euh merci beaucoup oui je
pense que que
dans d'abord oui je vais raconter un
petit peu donc comme vous voyez sur la
première page ce donc ce ce document en
fait on l'a on l'a on l'a adopté à on
l'a adopté à à
Stockholm assz tôt vendredi matin il
c'est c'est été officiellement adopté à
8h du matin euh voilà ensuite il y a une
conférence de presse de
présentation moi-même je suis allé à
Nant ensuite le au sommet des maires
parce que je pense que les territoires
et les maires doivent jouer un rôle
important dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et puis j'ai
déjà fait beaucoup de présentations
comme Raymond l'a rappelé depuis enfin
hier aujourd'hui et mais je suis très
heureux d'être avec vous euh c'est vrai
que je pense que que ce rapport a le
mérite de la
clarté peut-être qu'il est qu'il est
disons de façon liminire je je je crois
intéressant de vous rappeler comment
comment on fait un rapport ça c'est
c'est une première chose alors comment
on fait un rapport disons le voilà nous
en sommes au 5e rapport
euh le 5e rapport est est disons sous la
responsabilité du bureau effectif du
bureau le bureau est élu en fait le
temps la durée d'un rapport les
précédent étaé en 90 95 2001 2007 et
celui-ci va se disons décliner entre
2013 et 2014 avec parce qu'il y a
différents groupes euh donc le groupe 1
sur les éléments scientifiques le second
groupe sur la les impacts les
l'adaptation les vulnérabilités et le
trisème groupe sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique vraiment disons
les les les ce qui peut être mis en
œuvre je je souhaite alors je souhaite
rappeler une chose c'est que qui est
souvent mal
interprété le rôle du GC n'est ni de
faire de la recherche ni de donner ni de
faire des recommandations c'est ni l'un
ni l'autre c'est très important le rôle
du GC notre mission elle est très
clairement définie c'est
de porter un diagnostic à intervalle
régulier qu'on a fixé à 6 7 ans sur
l'ensemble des aspects
liés au roule potentiel des activités
humaines sur le climat ça c'est donc
c'est simplement faire un diagnostic
c'est surtout pas faire des
recommandations faire un
diagnostic c'est ce qui nous a amené sur
les sur l'ensemble des des des aspects
liés au réchauffement climatique enfin
disons lié au rôle des activités
humaines sur le climat c'est ce qui nous
a amené pour couvrir tout le champ des
des disons des domaines d'intérêt à
faire ces trois groupes en plus il y a
disons un rapport de synthèse qui sera
publié en octobre prochain et euh donc
nous partons avec un un bureau de de 30
personnes dont le président est et Ragen
r petchery enfin était pour le 5e donc
nous avons mis en place ce bureau ce
bureau en disons juste après le rapport
2007 début 2008 ce bureau se met en
place et au sein de ce bureau en fait il
y a il y a disons 30 nous sommes 30 donc
au sein du bureau c'est donc de pays
différents hein donc c'est un un système
très Nations Unies puisque le GC est
sous disons
sous la tutelle ou de deux organismes
des Nations Unies
le disons le programme le programme le
PNUE le Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'environnement et puis l'OMM
l'organisation métologique mondiale donc
ce ce bureau mais ce bureau n'a n'a
disons le le le vrai pouvoir c'est dans
les représentants bien sûr c'est les
pays qui décident ou non de l'existence
du GC et quià chaque étape effectivement
approuve parce que gement ils approuvent
l'action du bureau donc au sein de ce
bureau on a des sous-bureaux si on veut
c'estd chacun des trois groupes à trois
bureaux de personnes et donc il y a six
personnes plus transversales le
président et d'autres quelques autres
des vice-président et et et donc c'est
vraiment la tâche de ce bureau de H
personnes de prendre la responsabilité
du
rapport concernant son domaine donc moi
je suis moi-même membre du bureau donc
du du groupe scientifique à ce titre
vice-président mais donc on a aussi deux
co-présidents qui sont un Suisse Thas
stocker et puis un chinois chindai donc
ce bureau se met en place sa première
tâche qu'on disons ça a été la première
année ça a été de disons on doit d'abord
présenter un puisque on va effectivement
faire appel à hauteur notre premier rôle
ou notre première tâche c'est de de
disons d' un peu de structurer le le le
futur rapport simplement des têtes de
chapitres parce que évidemment si on
veut comme on veut les auteurs dans dans
chaque chapitre il faut quand même qu'on
qu'on identifie ce que quels sont les
différents chapitres ça ça nous a pris
une année on discute avec la communauté
scientifique avec effectivement avec il
y a aussi une assemblée pliniiaère qui
qui peut donner des avis et nous sommes
arrivés à à disons à à une structure un
peu différente dans le 5e rapport par
rapport au 4e par exemple dans dans le
5e rapport il n'y avait dans le 4e il
n'y avait pas de de de chapitre dédié au
niveau de la mer on avait un peu
éparpillé tous les aspects niveau de la
mer dans différents chapitres et ça vait
peut-être disons euh nuit à la
visibilité de de de ces de ces
projections sur le niveau de la mer on
en a de nouveau remis un dans le 5è
rapport qui est effectivement très
important donc par exemple on a scindé
le chapitre de projection un peu alors
disons effectivement courroi de
transmission entre la demande je dis
politique au sens noble du terme parce
que l'idée quand même c'est que j'aime
bien le dire en anglais c'est qu'on doit
être policier relevant c'està-dire que
ce qu'on raconte on est ça doit être
disons c'est censé vous intéresser les
décideurs po ou économique c'est censé
vous intéresser donc ça doit être
policié relevante mais pas policer
prescriptif c'est très clair
donc donc on a par
exemple on a eu des demandes donc ça se
passe à travers enfin a des organismes
de de de transmission on a eu des
demandes disons entre la COP donc la
conférence climat et puis ça j'en
parlerai après et puis disons la
convention climat et puis puis le GC qui
sont quand même indépendants la demande
éit d'avoir des des un peu plus l'œil
sur des projections à court terme et des
projections régionales et c'est pour
cela qu'on a scindé ce chapitre
projection en deux parties disons ce qui
risque de se passer d'ici 2050 et pour
l'après 2050 est dans le long terme donc
voilà ça c'est la première année on
restructure un peu le le le rapport on a
14 chapitres cette fois au lieu de 11
dans le précédent 12 et après on fait
donc on fait appel à hauteur et je crois
vraiment
que disons la qualité du rapport du GC
la sa visibilité aussi tient au fait que
que actuellement enfin il reste toujours
et c'est c'est vrai depuis la création
du GC en 88 et bien ça ça reste un
honneur dans notre communauté de d'être
auteur du GC je ve dire c'est vraiment
un honneur ça ne rapporte rien ça prend
du temps mais c'est très intéressant
scientifiquement parce que effectivement
on disons on rtoit des collègues de de
de disciplines différentes c'est
forcément intéressant mais si si bien
qu'on a vraiment on a vraiment de
nombreuses candidatures pour être auteur
hein ça peut transiter par différents
canaux ça peut être soit soit par les
représentants des gouvernements chaque
gouvernement évidemment un représentant
auogc en France c'est Nicolas berot qui
qui est aussi disons secrétaire général
de l'onercin donc au ministère de de
l'environnement ça peut aussi transiter
par des organisations scientifiques
disons internationales ça peut aussi
transiter disons de façon et et aussi le
bureau si on pense qu'il y a qu'il y a
effectivement un domaine qui n'est pas
couvert on peut aussi solliciter des
directement des auteurs mais ça nous est
rarement arrivé en fait là on avait 1000
candidats pour pour un peu plus de 200
auteurs donc les auteurs c'est à peu
près une douzaine par chapitre avec
comme premier critère de sélection la la
qualité scientifique mais c'est vrai
aussi qu'on tient compte de la de on on
a un souci de de répartition
géographique à peu près quand même
équilibré parce que si on regardait que
que le nombre de publication évidemment
ça ça ferait peser la balance beaucoup
trop vers les vers certain nombre de
pays un nombre de pays et puis
et puis aussi bien sûr le le genre je
veux dire qu'on souhaite avoir le
renouvellement si on souhaite que que là
il y a eu 60 % de renouvellement des
auteurs ce qui ce qui est bien c'est
bien d'avoir une certaine continuité
c'est bien aussi d'avoir des jeunes qui
s'impliquent donc on essae d'avoir
disons 60 70 % de renouvellement c'est
très bien il faut aussi certains qui bon
je pense que c'est bien d'avoir une
certaine et puis voilà donc on part avec
les auteurs
donc je souhaite dire
ici bon la dans ce rapport la France par
exemple donc est très présente en fait
nous sommes en nombre parce que je crois
que les auteurs ça nombre d'auteurs
représente quand même un peu une je
crois donne une image de
de disons de
de je dirons de la science qui se fait
dans dans pays et nous sommes dans ce
cas 3e après après les États-Unis qui a
60 représentants les les 25 pour les
pour le Royaume-Uni on est à 17 et après
ensuite il y a l'Allemagne la Chine
l'Australie le Canada donc on est en 3e
position ce qui est bien la comm
scientifique française est très active
et ça sur tous les domaines couverts les
les données du passé les observations
observations satellitair cycle du
carbone projection du climat aérosol
tout ça c'était on est on on est bien
présent son disciplines où disons aussi
bien sur Paris Toulouse mais aussi dans
d'autres points Grenoble Marseille
Bordeaux je pourrais citer Lille aussi
il y a vraiment une présence de de de
scientifiqu sur tous ces aspects qui
touchent on parle bien ici des éléments
physiques du changement climatique voilà
donc ensuite les les les auteurs donc se
mettent en en place il y a il y a une
première séance de travail en fait il y
aura quatre séances de travail espacé de
6 à 7 mois première séance de travail où
tout le monde se retrouve on fait un
disons une version zéro qu'on circule en
interne la deuxième version après la la
seconde séance de travail et c'est là
que ça commence disons je crois la le
vrai sens de l'expertise elle est
envoyée à tous ceux qui souhaitent la
lire apporter des commentaires c'est
très ouvert et en fait nous nous avons
nous avons ouvert de façon la plus large
possible tous ceux qui nous ont demandé
à faire des commentaires ont été
bienvenus he c'est très clair donc cette
première séance de revue ce se disons et
après il y a y a quand même un mécanisme
qui fait que disons les les auteurs de
du du chapitre sont doivent répondre
impérativement à tous les commentaires
ils peuvent dire que le commentaire
n'est pas pertinent ou B ou ou que qu'il
est pris ou qu'il appartient à un autre
chapitre mais il doit y avoir une
réponse ensuite il y a donc une version
cette à partir de de la 3ème séance
rentre justement pour un peu vérifier
disons le le le disons la la fluidité du
mécanisme je dirais des review éditeurs
c'est-à-dire des des gens qui sont qui
ne travaillent pas sur le contenu mais
qui vérifient simplement que aussi bien
du point de vue éthique pratique
fluidité et bien tout se passe bien hein
c'est le rôle des review éuditeur
moi-même j'ai été comme je suis membre
du
bureau disons je je suis j'ai aussi été
review éditeur du chapitre sur le niveau
de la mer c'est-à-dire mais donc voilà
et puis donc là ensite ensite il y a une
revue dit gouvernementale après la 3è
semaine généralement euh disons les par
exemple Nicolas Berriot en France se
retourne vers la même communauté
scientifique ça revient même si la N
gouvernementale c'est de nouveau
vraiment les mêmes scientifiques qui
sont sollicités pour apporter des
commentaires et puis donc là c'est c'est
c'est ficelé pour ce qui concerne les
chapitres après cette une 4e séance de
travail et bien sûr beaucoup de travail
entre-temps pour les auteurs les auteurs
travaillent consacrent beaucoup de temps
à à la rédaction du rapport sur sur 2 ou
3 ans je dirais et puis en parallèle on
commence la donc ça ce sont des un gros
rapport he ça fera 1000 pages qui sont
déjà disponibles sur le web tout est
disponible alors c'est complètement
transparent c'està-d qu'actuellement
tout est disponible aussi bien les
commentaires les réponses qui sont qui
ont été apporté nous-même en tant que
review auditeur on a fait un rapport sur
sur le fon enfin sur le mécanisme
lui-même si on a dit voilà ça va il y a
des points qui qui peuvent être
améliorés tout cela hein donc tout cela
est tout cela est disponible hein je
veux dire qu' il y a une transparence
complète alors ça n'a pas été disponible
pendant le processus hein euh
techniquement c'est peut-être pas
disponible aujourd'hui mais je sais
enfin déjà les les chapitres sont
disponibles on va tout mettre tout tout
va être sur site he toutes les versions
et tout cela donc et en parallèle se met
en route un disons la rédaction dans ce
qu'on appelle un résumé technique on
passe de 1000 pages à 50 pages et
ensuite un résumé pour décideur qui fait
15 à 20 pages donc on arrive à Stockholm
avec sur table un un résumé pour
décideurs euh on a déjà tenu compte de
premières remarques des de de de
premiers commentaires des
euh disons des des des gouvernements euh
voilà et puis euh se passe ce processus
d'adoption donc il y a une cinquantaine
de scientifiques qui sont là c'est bien
sûr sous la responsabilité des euh des
co-présidents de de de notre groupe et
euh alors ce que je souhaite dire c'est
que dans ce processus d'adoption
contrairement à une idée reçue le le
rapport reste complètement la propriété
des scientifiques parce que ne peuvent
être changés c'est important parce que
je je vous témoignez de ça parce qu'on
entend tellement de choses qui sont
fausses sur le rapport du GC je vous
assure euh donc c'est
donc ce que peut faire ce que peut faire
un disons un pays un représentant d'un
pays s'il veut il peut pas changer de
chiffre il peut éventuellement aller
chercher des chiffres mais disons tous
qu'il avance ou souhaite mettre en avant
doit trouver son origine dans le rapport
principal al évidemment les chiffres qui
sont le rapport principal ce sont qu'on
retrouve dans dans le dans le rapport
résumé pourer qu'on propose et euh
généralement ça se traduit et moi j'ai
vécu pratiquement une vingtaine ou une
quinzaine avec tous les rapports de de
processus
d'adoption effectivement ça se traduit
par le le contenu du rapport n n'est pas
modifié et euh dans dans le fond hein
mais disons ça bon finalement la forme
est généralement un peu modifiée pas
beaucoup hein franchement par exemple
pour vous dire je vais je vais je après
je vous présenter les les résultats
principaux du rapport pour pour pour
vous dire de façon très simple euh c'est
à la demande des chinois mais aussi des
Américains la seule modification
réellement où il y a eu des nouveaux
chiffres qui sont rentrés il y en a
jamais eu de supprimés ces chiffres
c'était des chiffres qui étaient dans
dans le rapport résumé technique c'est
qu'on dit j'y reviendrai parce que c'est
très important parce que le message
politique est très clair disons on
évalue on donne un chiffre en milliards
de tonnes de carbone euh auquel on a le
droit en gros euh si on ne veut pas
dépasser euh une certaine un certain
niveau de température évidemment il y a
pas donc voilà donc nous avions mis ce
chiffre enfin 270 milliards de de de
tonnes de carbone sous forme de CO2 nous
avons ce chiffre initialement avec la
probabilité disons que que que le enfin
bon disons pour se donner de bonnes
chances pour c'était pour se donner de
bonnes Chan que enfin plus de chance sur
trois que que le que le réchauffement
n'excède jamais de degré par rapport au
préindustriel on dit que il faut pas
plus émettre plus de 270 milliards de
tonnes et et simplement bon disons ça a
passé toute la nuit hein pour décider
que il fallait pas simplement mettre la
probabilité que vous avait deux chances
sur TR de ne pas dépasser de degrés il
fallait aussi mettre la probabilité une
chance sur de et une chance sur 3 donc
effectivement il y a trois chiffres mais
je veux dire par là que les chiffres ne
sont pas des chiffres inventés nouveaux
ce sont des chiffres qui viennent
effectivement du rapport principal donc
vous voyez c'est ce que je veux dire
faut quand même bien penser que ce
processus
d'adoption il n'est il n'est pas il
n'est pas pas une perte de propriété
pour pour la communauté scientifique par
contre il est très fort il est très fort
pour moi et c'est c'est ce qui fait la
visibilité du siècle parce que parce que
une fois qu'il est adopté il est adopté
par les représentants des gouvernements
qui se l'appropri et qui finalement
l'emmène avec eux he c'est bien ça qui
est important le mécanisme il est fort
parce que l'adoption une fois que les
les gouvernements l'ont adopté en fait
il s'en servent c'est bien ce qui se
passe et si moi je vais à toutes les
conférences climat et et je vous assure
et je le redis à chaque fois le livre de
je fais des négociateurs ce sont les
rapports du GC hein et c'est grâce à ce
mécanisme d'adoption bon une fois que je
ai parlé de tout ça donc on va venir un
peu à je sais vous vous connaissez déjà
un peu de ce ce don bon voilà vous
connaissez déjà un peu ce bon je vais
pas redire tout cela hein euh
excusez-moi j'ai gardé les j'ai voulu
garder on on a un texte en français hein
voilà qu'on peut vous peut-être je peux
vous l'envoyer je pe hein parce que je
que j'ai remis au enfinà on a eu on a eu
donc quand on est mercredi donc lundi on
a eu effectivement le le le
le le président de je te le donnerai
après
je te l'enverrai oui je l'enverrai donc
on a eu effectivement
déjà enfin des événements quand même
assez marquants puisqu'on a remis donc
on a eu une disons à l'initiative de de
Laurent Fabius une réunion au ministère
de des Affaires étrangères qui sont les
les les pilotes donc disons de la
conférence 2015 donc ça
c'était lundi matin donc en présence de
jeunev forazo de Pascal campfin on a eu
aussi la après-midi une réception à
l'Élysée on a remis en main propre enfin
j'ai remis en main propre avec quelques
collègues à François Hollande ce rapport
donc ça montre aussi l'intérêt quand
même de je crois du de nos décideurs de
nos politiques de notre monde politique
dans ce cas de de notre gouvernement
président de la République pour pour
cela il nous avait d'ailleurs déjà
écouté avant la COP en décembre dernier
nous avons eu un petit déjeuner avec lui
sur ces aspects climat donc euh voilà je
je je vais balayé donc vous avez sous
les yeux je pense que vous connaissez
donc notre notre première ben je vais je
vais lire en je vais vous dire en
français le réchauffement du système
climatique est sans équivoque euh et
depuis des années 1950 beaucoup des
changements observés sont sans précédent
hein c'est sans équivoque et sans
précédent hein c'est un double
qualificatif sur les dernières décennies
au derniers millénair l'atmosphère et
l'océan se sont réchauffé c'est
important le tendu et le volume des
neiges et Glac ont diminué et niveau de
la mer s'est élevé hein alors c'est un
c'est linguistique très clair que que
qui est ustré par par disons là je crois
que j'en suis à la page 3 ou 4 ou 5 donc
par par ces premières figures que vous
voyez là donc évidemment on vous invite
quand on regarde le climat on vous
invite à ne pas regarder enfin on ne
s'attend pas du tout à ce que le climat
se réchauffe année après année hein mais
disons que on s'intéresse plus à à des
échelles de temps de la décennie hein ce
qui est montré dans le dans le graphhe
du tessous et je reparlerai si vous le
souhaitez du ralentissement quand on
regarde dans disons non pas la la
dernière décennies a été très chaude
hein c'est de loin la plus chaude mais
si on regarde à inérieur de la dernière
décennie effectivement il y a eu un
ralentissement du du du réchauffement
qui ne remet pas du tout en cause le
diagnostic de réchauffement lui-même
mais sur lequel je je je voudrais bien
répondre à vos questions si vous en avez
alors la page suivante ça illustre un
peu ce qui ce que ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai dit alors c'est que euh et c'est ça
le réchauffement c'est déjà ce qu'on
avait dit en en 2007 c'est-à-dire que
quand on parle de réchauffement
climatique euh et bien c'est euh c'est
c'est pas simplement la température il
faut bien comprendre qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autres indices du réchauffement et
c'est ce qu'on avait dit en 2007 et ce
qu'on redit ici donc là il y en a
d'illustrer quatre qui sont les les les
plus les plus clairs pour nous disons ce
qui se passe dans l'océan de surface
c'està-dire que la chaleur s'accumule
disons il y a y a il y a une
augmentation de la quantité de chaleur
dans l'océan de surface correspond
simplement à une une augmentation de de
température sur une certaine épaisseur
je crois que c'est 70 m dans ce cas-là
ensuite vous voyez que la disons la la
couverture de neige alors c'est
essentiellement elle se elle varie
essentiellement sur ces variations sont
limitées à l'hémisphère Nord hein ça ne
varie pas dans l'hémisphères Sud
puisqu'il y a que l'Antarctique et après
des des continents n couverts de neige
plus au nord et bien cette couverture de
neige elle a elle a diminué en depuis
les années depuis la la la première
partie du du du 20e siècle très
clairement de moins 2 ou 3 million de
kilm²r euh vous voyez donc évidemment là
aussi ça fluctue d'un d'une année sur
l'autre hein c'est il faut faut pas euh
voilà donc ça c'est c'est c'est quand
même de à disons 3 milliards 4 à 5 fois
la France en moins qui est enneigée à la
fin de l'hiver qu'il n'y a qu'il n'y a
40 ou 50 ans dans l'hémisphère nord
c'est de même des choses qui sont bien
connues c'est c'est la diminution de la
la superficie de de la banquise dans
dans dans l'océan Arctique euh donc là
aussi ça varie d'une année sur l'autre
le minimal a été attendu éé été obtenu
en 2007 c'était 3 3.7 en dessous de 4
million de kmè Carr on est remonté en
dessus de 5 mais il y a il y a vraiment
une tendance
disons la décroissance du de de la de la
couverture de de glace dans dans
l'Artique qui vous le verrez risque de
nous emmener une disparition alors ça
c'est à la fin de l'été hein bien sûr
c'est à la fin de l'été c'est la c'est
la surface minimale euh donc
ensuite ce qui est peut-être le plus
parlant en tout cas pour moi c'est c'est
l'élévation du niveau de la mer
l'élévation du niveau de la mer ça
conjugue deux deux en fait deux
phénomènes qui eux-mêmes sont
je dis le fruit du réchauffement
climatique d'une part c'est comme il y a
plus de chaleur dans l'océan et bien il
y a a il y a une exp on appelle ça
expansion thermique une dilatation
disons tout
simplement et puis comme et puis il y a
aussi tout ce qui nous vient des des des
glaciers c'est la fondte des glaciers
alors à peu près pour donner une idée on
est à peu près à 3 mm sur un rythme
d'élévation de 3 mm par an 30 cm par
siècle à peu près actuellement de ces 3
mm il y a à peu près 40 % qui vient de
de de Antarctique du du groenlande et de
l'Antarctique de l'Ouest 20 à 30 % des
des glaciers continentaux des autres
glaciers donc disons tempérés en tout
cas hors région polaire et puis
l'expansion thermique aussi pour pour
un/ers donc mais ce que je veux dire ça
c'est vraiment une l'élévation du niveau
de la mer est vraiment une un indicateur
euh disons global du réchauffement
climatique en un seul chiffre disons
montre bien le le le réchauffement là
aussi il y a quelques fluctuations année
après année parce qu'il peut y avoir par
exemple une année où il y a plus de
pluie hein donc on peut avoir des des
différences dans dans le stockage de
quantité d'eau sur l'océan simplement
parce que le régime des précipitations
est différent d'une année sur l'autre
hein par exemple c'est c'est le cas de
d'e des événementsignau hein ça se ça se
disons ça ça joue sur le niveau de la
mer simplement parce que les régimes de
précipitation peuvent être assez
différents d'une année sur l'autre voilà
donc le le le le point suivant qui est
qui est que et bien le pour ce qui
concerne lui-même
donc on en passe au point suivant que
qui est ce qu'on
appelle le forçage climatique donc tout
ce qui peut donc tout ce qui est
susceptible
de disons d'influencer le climat donc on
a tout ce qui donc ce ce qui est vous
avez d'abord bon je pense une courbe qui
est un peu symbolique qui est celle de
l'augmentation de gaz carbonique c'est
quand même le gaz carbonique donc qui
est à l'utilisation du du du pétrole du
du charbon et du gaz naturel mais
également un peu à la
déforestation un peu je dis à peu près
10 % actuellement euh c'est pas
négligeable et et on voit cette montée
imperturbable du gaz carbonique alors
elle est elle est effectivement un peu
différente quand vous êtes au pôle Sud
où il y a presque pas de cycle
saisonnier euh par contre elle est
extrêmement marquée donc il a un cycle
saisonnier marqué au au disons dans
l'hémisphère nord et vous avez en en
trait disons où il y a plus de variation
euh ce ce sont les les les données
correspondant à à cette station avec des
variations saisonnières très marquées et
ça a été assez symbolique cette année
donc bien sûr on a arrêté les données au
moment de de c'était à fin juillet
disons à la fin de l'année dernière donc
on n avons pas les données des plus
récentes il y a que les données de 2011
mais en 2012 et bien euh de façon au
printemps 2012 c'est là où il y a le pic
disons la fin de l'hiver parce que après
la la végétation se met en route et ça
absorbe de nouveau du gaz carbonique
hein bien sûr c'est là que l'absorption
se joue et bien la la la barre des 400
parties par million jeis vous savez on y
a eu beaucoup de disons de nouvelles
autour du fait que que le CO2 était plus
son les la barre des 400 partis
marmillion venait d'être dépassé euh
bien sûr c'est de façon saisonnière mais
dans 2 3 ans elle sera elle sera
dépassée en en moyenne globale voilà un
peu pour et puis après mais je vais
c'est je vais je vais pas trop
simplement pour pour donner le le
sérieux du rapport vous voyez il y a il
y a disons un inventaire de toutes les
de tout ce qui peut modifier le climat
bien sûr le le méthane est quelque chose
d'également important euh les disons les
alocarbones les CFC voilà donc tout cela
je vais pas vous voilà ce que ce que je
veux simplement montrer c'est que c'est
fait de façon très sérieuse on essaie
aussi d'évaluer les forçages naturels ce
qui est lié par exemple à disons aux
variations de l'activité solaire et
c'est effectivement très faible hein
quand on parle c'est c'est toujours
l'objet d'un débat mais il faut quand on
commence un débat disant disant entend
quelqu'un dire que c'est l'activité
solaire qui est qui est à l'origine du
réchauffement actuel ce qu'on entend
toujours euh faut quand même savoir que
d'un côté on a 5 cenè de W par mètre
carré de l'autre on a près de 3 W par
mère carré hein donc il a il y a
vraiment un rapport euh disons disons un
rapport de de de largement plus de 10 20
ou même 40 ou 50 entre entre les disons
en terme de Wat par mètre carré ce que
ça ajoute en terme d'énergie euh et puis
quand on regarde aussi sur les sur sur
les 50 dernières années et bien
l'activité solore aur plutôt tendance à
légèrement diminuer simplement pour
souigner les difficultés disons
d'accepter cette explication de de
forçage solaire qui revient
régulièrement hein malheureusement bon
mais c'est ainsi mais qui revient
régulièrement c'est le soleil qui qui
est en train de de de de modifier le
climat et non pas les activités humaines
moi j'aimerais mieux hein mais
malheureusement c'est pas le cas voilà
euh donc ensuite alors la question qui
nous est posée de façon
de de de de façon
vraiment récurrente et vous voyez que
sur sur une des premières pages j'avais
montré la la progression de cette
réponse en 90 peut-être en 90 on savait
pas la question elle est c'est ça qui
c'est celle qui vous intéresse qui vous
intéresse qui nous intéresse qui
intéresse l'homme de la rue qui
intéresse les
journalistes
c'est je crois qu'on nous écoute pas
quand on dit que
euh effectivement le problème c'est pour
la 2è partie du 21e siècle que les
réchauffements importants c'est si on ne
fait rien c'est pour la 2uxè partie du
21e siècle que disons si on ne fait rien
tout de suite et et si on ne fait rien
au cours de cette décennie on ira
vraiment vers des des des niveaux d'ffit
ser qui seront directement je dirais
compatibles avec un développement
harmonieux de notre civilisation quand
on dit ça ça n'intéresse pas beaucoup
les gens hein il il n'écoute pas ce
qu'on dit pour la fin du siècle et quand
on dit en plus ce qui intéresse c'est
mais est-ce que le rchauffement
d'aujourd'hui c'est déjà lié au
réchauffement aux activités
humaines cette question elle est
récurrente elle nous est posé à chaque
rapport c'est normal et on la l'examine
de nouveau à chaque rapport à partir de
dire ce que je veux dire le débat n'est
jamais clos on vous dira jamais que le
débat est clos hein sonut pas quand on
dit que le on n jamais dit que le débat
est clos à chaque rapport nous reprenons
ce problème d'attribution du
réchauffement
climatique disons de d'essayer de faire
la part de ce qui est lié
disons de qui est d'origine naturelle et
ce qui est éventuellement lié aux
activités humaines on est passé de on ne
sait pas à 90 peut-être en
95 non oui enfin oui non peut-être en
2001 de de alors c'était très très très
disons même en 95 il y a peut-être plus
d'une chance sur deux en gros et ça va
jouer j'ai un rôle le fait simple le
simple fait de dire qu'on qu' y avait
plus d'une chance sur deux qu'on était
déjà dans un monde dont on modifiait le
climat avait joué un rôle Pr pondérant
dans dans la mise sur pied du protocole
de Kyoto en 97 on est passé à de Chan
sur 3 en en
80 oui en en 2001
et disons à plus de 9 Chan sur 10 en
en 2007 et et là on a disons alors un
diagnosti très clair il est doublement
clair disons le l'influence desactivité
humaines on le dit simplement il est
clair
heinire euh
donc mais le le le point important c'est
qu'il n'est pas simplement alors il y a
deux points qui sont importants on
devient plus précis hein donc on devient
plus disons notre conclusion est encore
plus ferme puisqu'on dit
que il y a plus de 95 Chan sur temps que
que le réchauffement récent des 50
dernières années soit soit dominé par
les activités humaines on pi bien
dominé ensuite ce qui est nouveau c'est
que on a on fait on limitait
l'attribution du réchauffement
climatique dans les précédents rapport à
la température moyenne de la planète là
on l'étend à beaucoup d'autres disons à
à d'autres aspects ça c'est important on
l' par exemple au niveau de la mer ou
même des aspects régionaux même à
certains extrêmes climatiques hein donc
et et le le le le troisème point c'est
que disons nous nous nous nous donnons
des chiffres sur les parts possibles de
euh disons des des des causes naturelles
et des et et des causes humaines al
évidemment dans les causes humaines il y
a les aérosols il y a beaucoup d'autres
choses tout ce que vous a lé tout à
l'heure en
gros la conclusion c'est qu'on pense
aussi la variité naturelle c'est-à-dire
que même si rien se rien ne changeait le
le climat n'est pas toujours pareil hein
même s'il y av aucun changement
d'activité solaire il y a toujours une
AC il y a toujours ce qu'on appelle la
varabilité naturelle on l'estime donc là
on parle d'une période de 50 ans à de
l'ordre de 11e de degré de même on
estime aussi que que disons que que les
causes naturelles enfin l'activité
solaire ne peut pas avoir joué pour plus
d'un diè de degré donc ça sur les
périodes sur une période où le
réchauffement était de de à peu près
entre 6 et 7 diè de degré à l'inverse on
est il est plausible que que le
réchauffement des des 60 dernières
années soit complètement dû aux
activités humaines he c'est très clair
soit entièrement dû donc ça c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose de qui qui
disons qui est plus clair parce qu'on
est enfin encore disons je crois qu'on a
qu'on a renforcé la conclusion de du
disons de de la responsabilité des
activités humaines dans ce réchauffement
par rapport au rapport précédent on
passe ensuite au je v pas être trop long
ça va aller on passe ensuite aux
projections alors là il y il y a une
nouveauté qui est quand même il y a une
nouveauté la nouveauté c'est
que donc cette fois disons dans le
précédent
rapport pour donc évidemment vous vous
comprenez bien que que le modilisateur
pour faire tourner ses modèles
climatiques il a besoin de savoir
comment va évoluer le l'effet de serre
dans
l'atmosphère donc on a toujours repéré
on se tourne on se tourne la communauté
des des modéisateurs du climat donc
celle donc qui sont plus euh dis sont
plutôt cell celle qui s'est impliqué
dans dans cette partie du rapport se
tourne vers les économistes qui eux
travaillent plutôt dans dans le 3oème
groupe et leur demande comment vous
voyez l'évolution de de notre monde en
terme de d'augmentation de serre ou
d'autres disons d'autres phénomènes par
exemple d'aérosol qui peuvent influencer
le climat alors les économistes nous ont
produit différents scénarios qu'on a
utilisé un plus ou moins émetteur en
fonction de la démographie la façon dont
on produit l'énergie dont on l'utilise
de de la façon dont on urbanise tout ça
c'est très bien simplement il y a quand
même un défaut c'est que si vous tournez
vers un économiste il est incapable de
vous fournir de façon naturelle un
scénario qui réponde à aux objectifs de
stabilisation qui sont inscrits dans la
convenion climat c'est aussi simple que
ça ils sont pas capables alors on a dit
on fait le contraire en gros là on est
parti de scénario où on dit on va
stabiliser le climat on va chercher à
stabiliser le climat et donc pour
stabiliser le climat il faut faut
d'abord stabiliser l'effet de serre
après ça prend un certain temps et
beaucoup de temps pour l'élévation du
niveau de la mer qui se poursuit donc on
a fixé différents niveaux de évidemment
on travaille sur différents scénarios de
nouveau des scénarios plus ou moins
évetteurs c'est-à-dire des niveaux de
stabilisation plus ou moins importants
euh donc un scénario qu'on appelle 2.6
c'est-à-dire c'est en terme de Wat par
mètre carré hein c'est c'est directement
c'est directement lié évidemment on peut
le lier directement aux quantités de de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
aux autres variables l'intérêt de cela
c'est qu'et effectivement on a quatre
scénarios qui à terme doivent nous
amener une stabilisation et donc là vous
voyez pas beaucoup mais le scénario le
plus émetteur qui est à peu près dans la
ligne du scénario le plus émetteur
précédemment on retrouve ces ces valeurs
très élevées de de réchauffement
climatique c'estàd qu'à la fin du siècle
le réchauffement peut aller jusqu'à 48
degrés la moyenne c'est un peu moins de
de 4 hein donc 3,7 je crois donc et la
valeur maximale a un peu plus de 5 hein
donc vous avez les barres à droite hein
c'est euh et euh ça fait quand même des
choses importantes si vous regardez
enfin on voit mal sur la la la disons la
la la copie mais euh un réchauffement de
de de 4°grés en moyenne globale c'est
plutôt 5 sur les continents he il y a
une amplification c'est plutôt 7 ou 8
dans les régions polaires Nord hein donc
euh ce scénario est à peu près identique
à au scénario le plus émetteur du du des
rapports précédent euh ensuite
euh donc à l'inverse donc donc le
scénario le moins émetteur celui qu'on
appelle 2.6 pas l'autre c'est 8.5 vous
voyez 2.6 c'est pratiquement on y est
déjà et bien le scénario moins émetteur
permet effectivement de de de rester là
en dessous de 2 degrés alors le problème
du scénario plus émetteur c'est qu' non
seulement on atteint 4 degr ce qui est
ou près de 4 degrés en à la fin du du
siècle en moyenne globale mais ça
continue les simulations certaines
simulations qui qui se poursuivent avec
ce scénario où la stabilisation est
assez à long terme se poursuiv et bien
on arrête arrive à je pourrais montrer
les les simulations françaises on arrive
à des à des à des réchauffements de de
plus de 10 degrés moyen en 2300 ça ne
s'arrête pas donc voilà donc
euh ensuite il y a bon je vais passer
assez vite d'autres phénomènes qui sont
comme on peut modéliser on pense que
dans les scénarios plus émetteurs la la
la glace de mer à la fin de disons à la
fin de l'été aura disparu dans l'artile
en horizon
2050 il y a aussi un autre problème dans
l'océan c'est l'acidification de l'océan
qui est déjà quelque chose visible
c'est-à-dire le disons ce qu'on appelle
le pH le jargon à diminué de d'un1è
d'unité c'est important c'est-à-dire que
disons il y a l'acidité c'est ce sont
des ions H+ donc il y a il y a déjà 25 %
de de disons d'acidité en plus je dirais
de façon un peu euh disons rapide qui
qu'il y a qu'au début du siècle et on
risque de de diminuer de de disons de
nouveau de deux disons de 2 diè d'unité
ce qui est très très important en terme
de d'influence sur sur la vie sur la
formation de de la calcite par exemple
les corau tous les animaux qui ont c'est
c'est plus difficile de former des des
coquilles de de calcaire quel qu'elle
soit après que ce soit des coquilles de
que ce soit des coquilles de crustacés
ou des Correau voilà donc c'est c'est
quand même des choses extrêmement
importante alors je vais pas beaucoup
m'étendre sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique parce que nous
aurons
donc tout ça va être détaillé
régionalisé dans le dans le de dans le
second rapport qui paraîtra en mars et
et je suis sûr que vous inviterez à
quelqu'un du second rapport pour venir
vous vous en exposer les résultats
l'élévation du niveau de la mer et j'en
aurai pratiquement terminé après
l'élévation du niveau de la mer les
chiffres sont plus élevés que dans que
dans le on arrive à des chiffres dans
dans le scénario plus élevé disons à la
fin du siècle de l'ordre qui peuvent
atteindre presque 1 m sur les valeurs
maximales de l'ordre de 80 cm dans les
valeurs
vraisemblables alors que disons elles
sont de de elles sont de de elles ntait
que de 20 60 cm dans le 4e rapport elles
sont plus élevé parce que nous avons
tenu compte de il ont mieux tenu compte
de la contribution du du Groenland qui
qui font effectivement assez à cette
contribution donc après vous avez bon un
résumé que je ne vous commande pas sur
sur les les l'élévation du niveau de la
mer et puis disons le réchauffement dans
dans les différents scénarios et ensuite
donc on on passe à quelque chose qui qui
est qui est quand même que donc si
maintenant on essayé de faire le lien
avec la comm son climat alors le le le
le le notre groupe n'a pas pour mission
de de effectivement de réfléchir aux
trajectoires disons qui pourrait nous
nous permettre de respecter les
différents scénarios ça sera fait dans
dans le groupe 3 mais on donne quand
même des chiffres globaux un peu disons
des des des signaux donc on dit que
disons que par exemple le scénario le
plus
faible permet de rester en dessous 2
degrés mais c'est probablement vraiment
le seul hein donc c'est important euh
ensuite bon je sur sur les émissions
elles-mêmes si on veut et après on donne
des chiffres pour pour le respect de ces
scénarios
euh donc disons le respect de ces
scénarios et bien ça vous donne un
chiffre qui qui qui pose vraiment le
problème le défi auquel on fait face si
on veut respecter le le scénario 2.6
CELI qui vaer en dessous de 2 degré et
il y a une une autre façon aussi de de
de le voir par la suite qui construit à
peu près au même chiffre euh donc c'est
c'est il nous reste 270 milliards de
tonnes de de CO2 à émettre euh ça c'est
bon en fait la la la meilleure façon
donc et c'est la phrase qui a donné
beaucoup de euh beaucoup de disons de de
grain moudde c'est là qu'on a en fait je
n'ai gardé que la probabilité 66 % mais
ça change pas beaucoup autrement
euh donc en gros notre droit à émettre
en terme là c'est plus on s'est on s'est
focalisé sur le gaz carbonique le droit
à émettre de gaz carbonique pour ne pas
dépasser de degrés sur l'ensemble de la
période d'émission c'est de 800
milliards de tonnes c'est très clair et
il y en a déjà eu 530 démises depuis le
début de la période préindustrielle on
retrouve ce chiffre de 270 milliards de
de de tonnes de de carbone donc chaque
année euh
oui je sais pas bon je vais arrêter là
chaque année effectivement on en est
c'est un peu le grave suivant à à 10
milliards de tonnes vous voyez si même
si on se maintenait au niveau actuel et
ça augmente ça n'arrête pas d'augmenter
on aurait plus que 27 ans de droit
d'émission euh et c'est de là aussi que
c'est une autre déduction qui correspond
à peu près à celle qu'on qu'on a d dans
dans le deuxème rapport à savoir que si
on voulait avoir des chances d'atteint
de de respecter ce type de scénario il
fallait absolument que que les émissions
commencent à redescendre d'ici 2020
qu'elles soit ensuite divisé par 3 entre
2020 et 2050 et que disons leur
diminution se poursuivent jusqu'à
pratiquement pas d'émission vers la fin
du siècle sinon des émissions négatives
ce qui est un gros mot mais qui est il
faudra peut-être disons replter des
arbres et absorber voilà un petit peu
l'essence du du du rapport et comme je
pas être trop long et répondre à vos
questions je fais arrêter là merci
Monsieur jean-josel alors Monsieur
remémi Poot
oui merci merci Monsieur Josel de votre
présentation
euh de ce rapport qui me paraît quand
même assez important pour notre planète
alors certains disent sur sur rapport
que vous faites du du
catastrophisme d'autres pensent que ce
n'est pas le cas
que vous sous-estimez même les effets du
du réchauffement
euh alors j'aurais deux questions
particulières d'abord c'est vrai qu'on
observe un ralentissement de de la
hausse de la température
moyenne lors de la dernière décennie euh
que les modèles n'avaient pas forcément
prévu puisquon on voit bien que l'née
passée était une période plutôt froide
pluvieuse avec des saisons bien marquées
comme c'est c'était le cas peut-être
autrefois alors comment interprète-t-on
ce phénomène et et que prévoit le
rapport concernant son
évolution et puis la deuxième question
plus plus générale comment
euh qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que pensent les
autres pays les plus émetteurs de de CO2
de ce rapport ça soit les États-Unis la
la Chine la Russie
l'Allemagne dans un monde en
compétition est-ce que c'est ça ça sera
leur priorité de de travailler sur le la
diminution de de gaz à effet de serre
par rapport à notre pays la France
l'Europe qui va faire peut-être plus que
d'autres des efforts et et qu'est-ce
qu'on pèse en Europe si on fait des
efforts d'accord mais par rapport à tous
ces pays qui risque d'en faire beaucoup
moins notamment la Chine qui j'ai pas
l'impression qui se soucie beaucoup de
de ces effets de réchauffement
climatique et qui sont dans la
compétition économique
mondiale je d'abord répondre à votre
avant de revenir aux aspects purement
climatiques à votre dernière au dernier
point d'abord je je je je je pense qu'il
faut voir c'est c'est c'est pas ni
catastrophiste ni bon je pense nous pour
nous ça représente une réalité je veux
dire la réalité c'est si on émet les gaz
carbonique d'autres gaz effet de ser on
IR échauffement important c'est une
réalité c'est pas c'est presque un fait
c'est ni de catastrophiste ni rien après
les disons les conséquences plus les
impacts seront plus seront plus disons
analysés par le groupe 2 bon les
sécheresses à répétition tout ça donc
tout ça ça reviendra mais c'est pas
c'est pas des points qu'on a qu'on a
vraiment abordé dans on n pas essayé
d'aller là donc si si on se place devant
une réalité c'est-à-dire que si on émet
ce qui va se passer très probablement je
peux vous dire c'est que bien sûr le
réchauffement va repartir je vous dirai
pourquoi parce qu'on est on est et
donc je je je crois qu'il y aura il y
aura quand quand disons quand quand
quand disons il y
aura la fin d'une civilisation carbone
est inéluctable il faut bien se mettre
ça en tête j'ai du mal je me suis
beaucoup impliqué dans la transition
énergétique on a du mal à faire
comprendre ça mais il faut faire
comprendre aux gens que la fin du tout
pétrole il faut arrêter cette addiction
au au combustible fossil c'est très
clair et les premiers qui le feront les
premiers pays qui le feront seront
économiquement gagnant il va y avoir un
nouveau rapport Stern c'est clair que ne
rien faire c'est catastrophique du point
de vue économique si vous voulez lire le
si vous prenez le temps 2 minutes je
vais essayer de donc de lire le quand
même le donc de de commenter peut-être
le le transparent suivant hein je je ne
l'ai pas commenté donc si vous commentez
celui-ci hein pour vous dire simplement
que euh disons ces conclusions que que
je vous ai que j'essayé de de partager
avec vous euh et bien elles sont si cell
des elles sont pas c'est pas cell de la
communauté scientifique il faut bien de
la communauté climat comme ça on n'est
pas dans notre monde on n pas dans une
bulle comme ça en train de vous dire des
choses qui sont complètement abstraites
regardez le diagnostic de l'IE agence
internation l'énergie hein le diagnostic
de laie est peut-être un peu plus
catastrophique encore que le nôtre donc
voilà le diagnostic de laie il vous dit
quoi il vous dit qu'on si on fait rien
d'ici 2017 on pe on ira au moins vers 3
degr demi de réchauffement sinon vers 6
hein ça c'est la les énergéticiens ce
sont pas les les climatologues qui
disent ça il faut bien comprendre ça
ensuite il vous dit surtout une chose
importante c'est que tout dollar non
investi cette décennie se traduira par 4
dollars à investir dans la décennie
prochaine donc même si vous on peut
discuter des économie et ça je le fais
c'est une erreur de ne pas lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique une
véritable erreur économiquement parlant
donc il faut bien avoir ça en tête non
je je vous le dis franchement maintenant
la Chine on va parler en 2015 on a cette
réunion à Paris elle va être importante
et si elle est importante c'est plutôt
grâce à la Chine qu'aux États-Unis ça
s'est décidé à durbane et à durbane on
aurait pas eu d'accord si la Chine à un
moment n'avait pas dit bien nous chinois
moi on est d'accord pour après 2020
avoir un accord qui nous qui nous engage
et qui éventuellement nous amène des
contraintes et les États-Unis ont é
obligé de suivre c'est pas le contraire
c'est c'est très important donc s'il y a
s'il y a la possibilité d'un accord pour
2020 il est loin d'être fait je vous
l'accorde hein mais c'est aussi les
Chinois qui l'ont qui l'ont accepté et
qui ont été presque un peu moteur hein
ensuite le dernier point il s'y prépar
ils sont les premiers en solaire les
premiers en en éolien les premiers en
nucléaire ils le sont bientôt euh ils
sont aussi les premiers en charbon je
suis d'accord hein mais ils ferment
quand même c'est vrai qu'ils ouvrent des
centrales mais à chaque fois ils en
ferment ils en fer des beaucoup plus
polluantes et de beaucoup moins
efficaces que celles qu'ils ouvrent et
euh donc on a regardé par exemple j'ai
un collègue Philippe siè qui travaille
sur les émission chinoise et
effectivement les régions les plus
développées de la Chine leurs émissions
commencent à descendre ce n'est pas vrai
pour l'ensemble de la Chine mais ça se
fera he donc il faut il faut bien voir
que la Chine se prépare d'abord ils sont
ils sont aussi très sensibles le le le
disons le cprésident chinois chindae est
un vraiment un ami puisque je le connais
depuis 20 ans il est aussi comme moi
glaciologue on discute on donc ils sont
très sensible aussi à la communauté
scientifique chinoise ils sont au premiè
loge des conséquences du réchauffement
climatique et ils le savent hein ils le
savent le franchement leurs
scientifiques sont là ils sont présents
et leurs scientifiques ont un message
très clair donc je crois pas non plus
qu'il faille agiter la Chine cette idée
que que que bah ne faisons rien parce
que les autres ne feront rien ne me va
pas bien voilà ça c'est très clair et
bon effectivement on en est là c'estàd
que l'Europe disons la la seconde phase
du protocole de Kyoto c'est l'Europe
plusques autres pays dis je crois
Nouvelle-Zélande Australie he bon et
donc c'est moins de 15 % des émissions
c'est vrai mais je crois aussi que il
faut pas il faut pas prendre ça comme
une punition aller vers une société
sobre en carbone il faut prendre ça
comme une opportunité au point de vue
économique parce que c'est aller de
l'avant et c'est aller en
avant donc je je je pense quand même
qu'il faut pas don donc je veux dire je
je je ne pense pas qu'il faille
euh vraiment je je comprends bien ces
arguments j'y fais face souvent je je je
me'y suis bon c'est vrai que je disons
que je je je me suis investi dans
d'autres choses que que que le
simplement que simplement mon rôle de
scientifique mais c'est vrai que j'ai
j'ai bon dans la transition énergétique
on pourra en discuter tout ça mais c'est
important on est venu d'ailleurs vous
vous en présenter les les résultats j'en
ai fait une disons un rapport sur
transition énergétique au niveau du CER
et je me suis impliqué dans dans le
débat national maintenant renons au
climat c'est plus intéressant
oui alors disons il faut d'abord il y a
il y a pas du tout a un ralentissement
disons qu'au cours des 15 dernières
années le réchauffement été de de 5 diè
de degré par des 5 cenè de degré par
décennie au lieu de disons trois fois
plus rapide que sur les 30 années
précédentes alors je veux dire d'abord
la première chose c'est que les modèles
contrairement à ce que vous dites prévoi
ce type de de chose c'està-dire que si
vous prenez un modèle sur 100 ans avec
une augmentation régulière du gaz à
effet de serre après année année après
année tous ces scénarios que vous ai
montré bien tous les modèles montre des
phases où il y a une des phases où il y
a disons un réchauffement rapide des
réchauffements plus lents et même des
fois des refroidissements donc tous les
modèles prévoi ça ce qu'ils ne savent
pas faire vous avez raison c'est ils ne
savent pas quand hein les modèles ne
savent pas prévoir ils prévoient tous
des montées des descentes aucune montée
tous les modèles prévoient ça parce
qu'il y a y il y a disons une
variabilité disons entre l'océan et
l'atmosphère qui fait que donc tous les
modèles prévoient vraiment des des
décennies où ça va plus vite des
décennies où ça va moins vite mais c'est
vrai que si vous leur donnez on a bien
vu ça hein dans si vous les faites
partir de 2000 et bien il y en a qui
feront une phase disons un
ralentissement en 2020 d'autres en 2030
c'est un peu le bordel donc on sa ils
savent prévoir disons c'est ça je veux
dire vous comprenez un peu ce que je
veux vous dire c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
sait pas prévoir quelle décennie
maintenant il faut quand même bien voir
surtout que tous les autres indicateurs
du réchauffement climatique sont au
rouge hein quand vous voyez l'élévation
du niveau de la mer qui se poursuit donc
c'est pas du tout ensuite ce qu'on
observe et ce qui est plutôt inquiétant
c'est-à-dire on observe que la chaleur
qui n'est pas dans l'atmosphère qui n'a
pas servi à r chauffer l'atmosphère on
la retrouve dans l'océan profond et ça
ça nous amène à nous poser des questions
quand est-ce qu'elle ressortira hein on
disons il y a il y a clairement euh plus
de chaleur dans l'océan profond qu'il y
en avait dans la décennie précédente et
puis il y a il y a aussi les causes
naturelles qui peuvent jouer par exemple
autant on peut dire que sur il faut bien
comprendre que autant on peut dire que
sur 50 ans le soleil n'a pas joué quand
vous regardez une décennie quand on
parle donc hein quand on parle donc
c'est c'est c'est donc ce qui ce qui
manque c'est un diè de degré par rapport
à l'avant hein on passe mais si on veut
passer et bien là on dit bien aussi que
le fait que le soleil a été plutôt
faible hein plutôt faibleard dans la
dernière décennie peut avoir joué un
rôle il y avait aussi plus de d'aérosol
dans la dans le disons dans dans dans
dans la haute atmosphère donc tout ça on
essae je ne dis pas qu'on peut le
prévoir mais je je pense qu'on peut
l'expliquer et je je je crois qu'on est
tous convaincus c'est bien pour ça la
force de agnostique que ça ne joue pas
disons le fait que ça a vite à des
moments et plus lentement à d'autres ne
joue pas sur la la projection à long
terme qu'on qu'on met en avant donc
c'est un peu ça ça ma réponse et je
pense je suis moi-même convaincu que le
réchauffement repartira malheureusement
à ce moment il sera trop tard pour
rester en dessous des 2 degrés et et
c'est vrai d'une certaine façon que et
bien c'est toujours disons l'argument
qui est mis en
avant disons dans Ça c'est arrêté donc
il y a plus de problème je c'est
malheureusement
faux bien alors Monsieur Alen
Foucher merci beaucoup monsieursieur le
Président Monsieur vous avez un expos
est très intéressant et très vrai vrai
que c'est très inquiétant et malgré tout
ce qui est écrit malgré tout ce qui est
dit les gens se sentent peu
sensibilisés parce que en fait le temps
pour eux est lointain et ils n'ont pas
ce
sentiment simplement je voudrais vous
poser une une ou deux petites questions
bon les besoins des consommateurs sont
de plus en plus élevés les gens sont
habitués à la clim ils veulent plus en
plus de clim et on de choses plus en
plus climatisé ça sans doute très
difficile de les arrêter
dire quel moyen pour faire appliquer
vous parliez à la fin de votre rapport
de Mure radical quel moyen pour faire
appliquer des mesures préconisées pour
faire c tout ce qui se passe auprès des
états bon les états industrialisés vous
expliquez les conférences qui se mettent
en place les volontés et ensuite par
rapport au pays non non industrialisés
qui aussi sont concernés quel moyens
aura-t-on pour vraiment faire appliquer
les mesures utiles nécessaires
indispensables je sais que ma question
est pas facile mais je sais que vous
pouvez répondre à tout non je peux
répondre à tout ou c'est un peu en
dehors du du rapport que je suis venu
présenter mais euh bon c'est vrai aussi
que je suis dans le comité
d'organisation de la conférence 2015 et
je peux pas me désintéresser de sa
réussite éventuelle bon par exemple j'ai
écouté Pascal campfin avec attention qui
qui je pense il sera fortement appliqué
euh l'idée de bon je pense qu'il faut
garder de l'ambition en terme climatique
mais l'idée de de de lier lutte cont
réchauffement climatique et disons
développement est quelque chose de très
important il faut bien voir quand on
parle de justement quand on parle de de
de potentiel disons c'est c'est c'est
clair que un continant comme l'Afrique
parce que c'est aussi là oùons la
démographie risque d'être galopante si
au cours des 50 prochaines années
pourrait en tout cas c'est c'est c'est
le premier continent qui pourrait
techniquement je parle techniquement se
passer de pétrole de charbon ils ont
tout ils ont ils ont du soleil à à gogo
de l'éolien de la biomasse de
l'hydraulique tout est là je veux dire
franchement ce sont des des des pays qui
pourrai très bien donc après c'est une
question de stratégie et tout ça je je
comprends bien mais par là je veux dire
c'est le pays où tout est possible si on
veut aussi hein donc je sais on en est
loin mais je veux dire li lié
développement et et lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique est quelque
chose qui qui qui est très certainement
important on on ne forcera pas ass si
vous voulez moi moi je suis venu ici en
tant que scientifique donc je veux
surtout pas comme surtout pas vous faire
de recommandations puisque c'est pas le
rôle du JEC donc je vous en ferai pas
euh mais je Seris une quand même donc je
pense que non je je je pense honnêtement
que on est dans un monde où l'économie
domine donc c'est très clair pour moi la
la seule façon de de disons de la seule
façon c'est que sont les les disons les
les énergies renouvelabl deviennent
compétitive c'est très clair donc que
disons que les en tout cas celle
nonémérice de gaz
carbonique on va pas faire un débat sur
le nucléaire ici mais voilà donc et pour
cela c'est c'est très clair que euh si
on donne pas un prix au carbone on n'y
Arria jamais on pouvait espérer à un
moment il y a une dizaine d'années euh
que que naturellement le le prix du du
gaz et euh du pétrole elle a augmenté
euh disons de façon importante euh
disons suffisante pour rendre sans sans
sans mesures particulièr compétitive
rapidement d'autres énergies on voit
bien qu'avec le gaz de schiste et
pétrole non convventionnel cet espoir
enfin espoir pour le climatologue hein
euh c'est envolé hein non mais je je je
j'ai beaucoupuss discuté vous inquiétez
pas je je j'ai travaillé sur la
transition énergétique je vous le redis
c'est pas le problème mais je veux dire
par là que si on donne pas de prix au
carbone pour venir à la conclusion sur
ce point si on ne sait pas donner un
prix au carbone au niveau international
et bien on narrivera pas à lutter contre
le réchiffrement climatique de de de
façon de façon efficace je je sais
l'échec des premiers quotas et tout cela
donc il faut il faut vraiment donc c'est
c'est un peu ça la voie qu'il faudrait
suivre merci monsieur le Président moi
aussi à mon tour je voudrais vous
remercier pour cet exposé très
intéressant alors bien sûr je sais que
vous nous dites vous êtes un
scientifique vous n'êtes pas là pour
nous donner des recommandations mais
nous avons quand même besoin d'un
certain nombre de de de réponsse et si
je me félicite moi que il y ait vraiment
un chapitre cette fois-ci sur la mer et
sur l'évolution des côtes nous sommes
nous les élus confrontés à la réalité
des choses il y a à la fois l'érosion
côtière dû à cette avancée quand même de
la mer et c'est pas en projection ça
existe il y a des zone en France et
ailleurs dans le monde où le trait C de
recul il y a les risques de submission
marine avec les les grands phénomènes
météo donc comment est-ce qu'un élu peut
essayer ou les élus en général peuvent
essayer d'anticiper parce que euh bon il
y a des populations sur ces zonesl vous
disiez 1 € qui n'est pas dépensé
maintenant ça un dollar ça sera 4
dollars dans le siècle suivant ou dans
les décennies suivantes euh voilà
comment fait-on on a des possibilité
d'avoir des des cartographies des
représentations de l'évolution du trait
de côte mais on n'a pas trop
d'information sur à quels endroits
précis ça va se passer on dit bon ça
risque de s'élever de 60 cm ou de 80 cm
ça sera pas 60 cm 95 cm partout il y
aura des nouveaux courants il y aura un
certain nombre de choses donc comment
anticiper alors il y a je essayer de
répondre rapidement d'abord bon c'est
évidemment pas dans ce rapport que vous
trouverez l'essentiel sur alors on
commence à parler effectivement d'un
point qu' dont on nait pas d'aborder
dans le pas vraiment abordé dans le 4è
rapport c'est que quand on parle de
d'élévation du niveau de la mer la
valeur moyenne ne veut pas dire
grand-chose ce qui ce qui est important
et en fait d'un endroit à l'autre de la
planète ça peut varier largement d'un
facteur 2 donc c'est c'est important
donc c'est important de de parce qu'il y
a des modification des courants donc une
augmentation donc ça c'est un premier
point important qui est mieux qu'
cartographieré que par exemple bon vaut
mieux pas être du côté de New York
actuellement parce que les sont du
niveau de la mer risque d'être 20 à 30 %
plus élevé que la valeur moyenne hein
donc ensuite il y a un deuxème point qui
est important c'est que l'élévation du
niveau de la mer le problème c'est pas
le niveau moyen bon ça ça rend la
difficulté plus forte mais c'est c'est
le problème de la houle des des grandes
tempêtes enfin disons une conjonction de
bon je sais pas vous faire un schéma
vous savez bien enent quand il y a
conjonction entre disons euh disons très
forte marée ooule très forte
précipitation sur le continent et bon on
arrive à des à des problèmes qu' on a eu
sur xintia c'est très clair donc c'estil
faut il faut les extrêmes les valeurs
extrêmes sont plus importantes dans
l'optique que vous regardez que que
celle alors ça ça va quand même mieux
traiter dans dans le rapport du Groupe 2
avec des valeurs régionales hein donc ça
euh c'est ça c'était pas l'objet de de
de notre rapport de le faire mais on a
bien ça en tête que c'est sont les
versions régionales qui qui sont
importantes ensuite bon du du du point
de vue euh bon du point de vue que vous
posez bon euh moi je me suis euh bon je
me suis beaucoup investi dans dans la
mise sur pied du plan d'adaptation
nationale adaptation au changement
climatique donc qui a été promulgué il y
a il y a 2 ou 3 ans maintenant par
natalieus commoris j'étais responsable
du groupe où en particulier nous
trations du niveau de la mer donc nous
ce que nous sommes fixés ce que nous
sommes fixés à
l'époque disons comme comme disons ligne
de de crête c'était que que
disons réfléchir à une France qui
pourrait qui pourrait dans certains cas
devoir faire face à une élévation du
niveau de la mer qui pourrait aller
jusqu'à 1 m hein c'est cette valeur
qu'on a prise euh et ensuite on a fait
des recommandations et et vous avez
raison et une des recommandations qui
que nous avions faites à l'époque c'est
vraiment qu'on y connaisseit rien
c'estàd qu' il y a pas de vrai travail
et c'est plus ce travail d'organisme
comme le vrgm le show il y a pas de vrai
travail à disposition des enfin des
maires des élus des régions côtières
pour savoir comment un niveau moyen se
traduira du point de vue local et ça ça
reste à faire mais c'était une des
recommandations de notre groupe de
travail je sais pas où ça en est mais
comme je vais travailler 16 sur un
disons sur un avis sur l'adaptation
réchauffement climatique on va peut-être
regarder tout ça mais je je comprends
bien que et je je suis très conscient de
ça du CE ce qui intéresse le le décideur
les décideurs que vous êtes politique
économique ce sont les les variations
locales régionales du du du changement
climatique et donc j'espère que que on
vous apportera plus d'éléments et au
niveau français que ben oui que que le
plan d'adaptation se mette vraiment en
route que disons qu'il y a vraiment cet
échange c'est
voilà je suis un peu surpris euh que en
fait à ma connaissance par rapport à la
possibilité qu'on les alus de de pouvoir
avoir quelques information très très
précis sur le rôle des de leur décisions
fait sur en fait en dehors de l'onerg je
je je suis je suis surpris on les a
auditionné souvenez et bien on ne trouve
pas d'organisme qui est vraiment en fait
des réelles évaluations qui pourraient
nous faire prendre conscience du coup de
programmer au fur à mesure que la
on monte en puissance en quelque sorte
vers la catastrophe c'est quand même
étonnant
qu'avec l'argent dont on dispose ne
serait-que pour faire quelques études on
n'est pas des traductions beaucoup plus
concrètes en dehors de l'honner qui est
un petit organisme qui dispose de peu de
moyens ils sont moins de 10 et et tu as
cité tout à l'heure donc
monsieur
mer il est aussi représentant de la
France auprès du GC ça prend une grande
partie de son temps mais c'est quand
même étonnant con que ce petit organisme
qui est chiffré euh ou en tout cas qui
essayé de le faire quoi voilà pardon je
v rajouter non non mais c'est vrai
monsieur de Marcel Denon
oui c'est pas la peine que j'insiste
pour vous dire tout ce que je pense de
de jean- jusel des travaux qui
conduisent bon ce que je voudrais il a
répondu aux principales objections qu'on
entend en permanence dans ce pays alors
c'est d'autant plus compliqué gens que
la France malgré tout est parmi les bons
élèves en matière d'émission si il
faudrait qu'on apprenne à comptabiliser
aussi nos émissions en ajoutant les
importations hein euh parce que les
émissions chinoises nous y participons
hein et ils sont pas comptabilisés dans
la consommation des Français il faudrait
aussi faire des bilan de ce genre bon
ensuite ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que si on veut faire pédagogie
mais c'est pas votre travail moi
j'admire depuis 15 ans que je vous
connais la discrétion des scientifiques
et la modestie surtout des scientifiques
ceux qui parlent c'est ceux qui en
général connaissent moins que les autres
enfin je le dis bon
alors pour nous mais même entre
scientifique des gens qui ne sont pas
des spécialistes de de du climat
émettent des jugements et notamment il y
a il y a une école de physiciens
français qui nous complique un peu le
dossier alors une question que je
voudrais vous poser dans les
consultation que vous avez faite pour ce
rapport les physiciens français du type
Gervet Allègre et quelques autres
ont-ils envoyé des communications et
quelle réponse leur a été faite on peut
les trouver quelque part ces réponses
c'est publié ou pas et puis enfin une
dernière observation je crois que du
côté pédagogie et compréhension dans
grand public il faudrait que des gens
comme vous mais comment faire on fasse
beaucoup de réunions régionales dans les
régions concernées moi dans la Picardie
nous sommes actuellement euh on a
sensibilisé les gens nous sommes en
train avec le Conseil Général de se
poser la question de savoir si on ouvre
une brèche pour pour inonder un pole
d'Ur qui fait 1000 haares on ça nous
coûte tellement cher à empêcher la mer
de venir qu'on se dit après tout mais
mais pour faire admettre qu'on va
inonder 1000 hectares avec des
habitations c'est quand même pas simple
mais on est en train de progresser alors
du côté bon je m'arrête là l'acidité de
la mer sur la Picardie avec nos
fallalages de Cré nous sommes très
sensible parce que si vous augmentez
trop plus vite l'acidité bon alors alors
tout ça compliqué expliquer tout ça pour
dire que si on fait des réunions
régionales sur des sujets précis où les
gens sont impliqués on arrive à
intéresser les gens autrement si on se
dit c'est pour la génération d'après on
verra bien quoi hein bon merci beaucoup
euh bon oui il y a toujours cette école
de enfin de physicien français mais bon
j'ai bon effectivement j'avais en face
moi
hier
Gervet franchement c'est j'ai c'est une
véritable imposture scientifique je le
dis franchement je veux dire c'est
quelqu'un qui qui n'a jamais travaillé
dans ce domaine qui dit des choses
complètement idiotes qui son livre qui a
beaucoup de succès c'est simplement
aller chercher sur des sites sur des
sites de scepti ce qui s'y dit c'est
c'est vraiment je je veux dire je
comprends pas non plus comment un
éditeur peut marcher là-dessus mais ceci
étant il faut moi j'accepte je je pense
qu'il faut accepter c'est ainsi euh bon
c'est pas le cas d'autres je dirais pas
que que Vincent Courtillot Alex c'est de
laimposture scientifique mais dans le
cas de de François Javet je me permets
de le dire parce que ce qu' dit vraiment
ça n'a aucun sens hein donc voilà donc
je veux dire euh j'ai rien contre
l'homme non plus il est très sympathique
donc mais mais mais donc qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire moi je pense qu'il faut ben
moi j'essaie à chaque fois d'accepter le
débat j'essaie d'accepter le débat de de
débattre d' c'est aussi à nous de
convaincre j'espère qu'on qu'on y arrive
un peu donc c'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire donc euh par exemple pour c'est
dans l'air évidemment m'appelle assez
souvent il me disent on va on va on va
voir François Gervet mes collègues m'ont
dit tu do avoir refusé j'ai dit non il
faut y aller c'est tout donc est-ce que
c'est mieux d'y être allé je pense que
oui et donc je voilà donc c'est mais
c'est des choses auquel on fait face
encore et des fois ça c'est vrai que ça
nous fait un peu mal mais bon mais il
faut l'accepter parce que d'abord le
scepticisme est en soi quelque chose de
très louable hein donc ça il y a pas de
problème je veux dire que les gens nous
posent des questions et se posent des
questions me gênne pas mais euh bon à un
moment c'est à nous de convaincre aussi
on essae à chaque fois avec ce rapport
du GC avec on essaye et puis on espère
on espère effectivement y arriver mais
bon c'est vrai que bon c'est facile de
mettre en avant le fait que au cours si
vous prenez les 10 dernières années
toutes les années ont été chaude et puis
bon j'ai pas voulu reprendre tout mais
c'est vrai que l'hiver ça n'a rien à
voir le fait que l'hiver en Europe était
plus froid il y a a en 2009 ou en 2010
les années globalement on étaient
chaudes il y a pas de problème donc les
fa le fait qu'on est bon on peu toujours
bon tout cela c'est tellement facile de
dire cela bon mais c'est aussi à nous de
redire si je viens vous essayer de vous
disons de partager avec vous c'est aussi
pour ça que je suis là pour redire ces
choses pour essayer de les redire
clairement voilà pour cette audition de
jean-jusel qui a été auditionné par la
commission du développement durable sur
le 5e rapport du GEC le Groupe
intergouvernemental d'experts sur le
climat qui a rendu cette autonne un
rapport assez alarmant sur le
réchauffement climatique vous pouvez
bien sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires
toujours novateur